everybody my name is Bonnie rose shulman
and I'm the managing editor of the
journal of Middle East Women's Studies
at Yale University the Journal of Middle
East Women's Studies is an academic
journal that aims to advance the fields
of Middle East Women's and Gender
Studies through contributions from
multiple disciplines in the social
sciences and humanities for more
information take one of the bookmarks
that are being passed around or visit
our website at www s org we are pleased
to be co-sponsoring this event with the
council and Middle East Studies at Yale
University's Macmillan center of
international and area studies and with
the Orville H shell junior center for
international human rights at Yale Law
School I want to especially thank Laurel
emoc and Amara Haider for translating
and for organizing the event today with
us today is some are ya spec a Syrian
writer novelist and journalist and
author of a woman in the crossfire
Diaries of the Syrian Revolution a woman
in the crossfire is a haunting insider's
account of Syria's bloody revolution and
the Assad regime's attempt to maintain
its control yasbeck was an active and
outspoken critic of the regime long
before the outbreak of violence her
prominence as a high-profile Alawite
journalist and author makes her
criticism all the more searing she was
denounced by her family and clan and
harassed by the security services as the
brutality mounted she was forced to flee
syria with her young daughter and she is
now in hiding what she's in the front
row open in her Diaries yazbek describes
the uprising that started in march two
thousand eleven and the ensuing brutal
response her observations are
interspersed with the testimonies of
those at the forefront of the revolution
whose accounts she has dedicated herself
to collecting yazbek studied literature
before beginning her career as a
journalist a script writer for syrian
television and film and a highly
regarded writer in syria her novels in
Arabic include child of heaven clay
cinnamon and in her mirrors cinnamon
will be released in English in November
copies of her recent New York Times
article are circulating were so
fortunate to have her with us today
please join me in welcoming some arias
back
hello thank you actually I prefer to
speak in Arabic an aside alangudi
vanakkam had the olin I'm very happy to
be here with you that's first worried an
isochoric AL has at Putnam and I want to
thank you going rose for this
introduction and all fidelis cotton and
Cornell Michelle musta been an ally who
are valakii Nicopolis Dalek so [ __ ]
will head east lee bottle rocket i
prefer that the the the time will be
here for both of us to interact and
conversate minh and do a conversation
but i'm gonna talk for a little bit what
I didn't say I had this Anelka tub I
wanna store Emmanuelle katavi i'm going
to talk specifically about the
revolution through my book Wally danica
find a much more min on the cot and I
want to stop and several points way in
the car ality attracted and now Anna Deb
do business bella como esta basura a
more formal the points that I think it
looks like for you at a gray and and and
and and easy not easy to understand
Philby diaura daddy son bday at
essaouira story a vivid Intifada sob
story and the beginning I wanna talk
about the beginning of the revolution
regime start tried try to escalate and
started the Secretariat wore that and he
needed a wanted to revolution to turn
into that another study say he had a son
as usual her third point I'm gonna talk
about the free army one mobile ahead le
TT melody sana you Jude al Qaeda was
sarafian which he had GFE and the
exaggerations about this in this free
syrian are
me included of al-qaeda and seller fees
and jihad is in it tabondant Oh Kermit
our future ullal essaouira by the atmos
my administer Bob battle cruiser bicycle
silly me finish mominul mood on well
Arya film Adonis Surya as you know at
the beginning of the revolution groups
of young activists try to gathered and
to demonstrate and the in small towns
and and the country sides of the Syrian
cities wanna Mortimer Fallon bill Hadees
aunt of seal has he'll be dying I want
to talk a little bit in details about
this beginning Dada clan thorat Tunis
wha masala Libya but a shabbos Arriba
tov kill by Shaquille GG be a now helm
helm in El Monte anantha come sorrowful
Surya after the revolutions in Egypt and
Tunis and Tunisia and Egypt and and and
and Libya the Syrian young activists
tried to think is it possible to have
such an uprising in Syria wokcano cot
beta OS tad Donley had al ameri brasa
fattah el facebook während ave alamosa
hot and they start preparing for that
through facebook pages and and the the
call for upright for demonstrations well
tomate Dawa dawat case here a little
[ __ ] fee-help medina damask multiple
ahem and there was a lot of these
invitations or calls to do
demonstrations inside the heart of
Damascus what can I sure have a double
tee time at film from stash but but
alpha nu e dash and the last one was on
the fifteenth of februari 2011 well
atiba at bluefish alta bond which was a
failure of course yeah Natasha Omaha
shabby and Philby Medina Canada Eve
because the response from the people
towards it in the heart of the city was
very weak well I mean ol mahabharat can
tell McCann Almo Sahara allergy can
muster anta comfy volver lemon story and
and because of the location of the of
the
the demonstration which is in front of
the Syrian Parliament was invaded and
occupied by the syrian security offices
and security forces and and the military
forces a bonfire let's not be dyed other
Hadas moham [ __ ] done oh my are they had
this folderol meanwhile and the big and
specifically in the beginning of March
something happens which is known as
direct children accent hazel comment
assist Emmanuel mahabharat better calm
as Mormon a las fallas sahar the
security systems and the and and
arrested a small group of little child
t-midi Nate vision obesity is manda
audubon and Dhara which is which is
which located in the South Syria come on
how alot file the magical home Lisa baba
see Jaden these kids were arrested for a
very simple reason attempt re phone not
valid Asaram BT Vision Catherine you
know kids take a lot of effects and take
a lot of attention from the TV well
crucial Arabiya Kenneth uncle char ashab
you read scott on his own and all the
arabic TV channels at that time we're
broadcasting their very very famous
slogan the people wanted to take down
the regime Fusaro at Folly october
knowledge Ronnie madrasa Asha be rude
Scott and Nizam so the kids wrote on
their school's walls the people want to
take down the regime for comet as you
still a member to call how a lot for the
security systems are arrested these kids
welcome will beat ICBM batteries Kashia
and they tortured the children in a very
horrible way what allow a la fura home
and to the point that they pull out
their fingernails well the whole vision
and put them in prison well Ms Elenora
him physician who LM inshallah is Bashar
al-assad and and there's the person
responsible of putting them in jail is
the cousin of above the President Bashar
al-assad
what if najib heart of Najib tab on the
hobble a heli lahaa watch out lady him
an incision for comma B honey Haley were
coming back to cali him what it called
battle my heart the parents want to take
their kids out of the jail and the demo
and demand their kids out of prison but
they they they beat them they they they
insult them and they arrested some of
them including some of the mothers film
some stash as a garage Ella Hal Bodley
Haley fedora och Reba Alma taka lien hua
achari aloo mesa well resolve ahora su
famosa her a lil mo talaga be at luck
Cera a lot follow a highly him on the
fifteenth of March some people from
their other relatives of the people who
were arrested the relatives of the
children and the woman who were arrested
and put in jail went into a
demonstration peaceful demonstration
requesting the release of the people in
prison turbine regimen while original
dread do vertical bad water bill bad
what cut a little bad the regime
security and soldiers respond while
arresting some and and beating the
others and killing some ken has a omaha
massage as our alpha dash this happens
on the fifteenth of march two thousand
eleven the bond films etosha national
kalamazoo Konoha regina famosa hara
amamos RT Delia he's a hottie margin on
scenes of Mahrt we went on a
demonstration in front of Ministry of
Interior and Damascus and merges square
way kuna le dynamo Talib howl o'clock
Sarah mata calera ecs even a surgeon
Surya and our demands was to release the
the the the opinion prisoners or
political prisoners from the Syrian
prisons the bantam c'mon almos ihara
Eden Patera kobashi the the
demonstration was
uh brutally was brutally the response
from the regime was terrible day they
brutally response today to the two
demonstrations durable Matata hareen
tackle Catherine min and miss our region
they beat the demonstrators and they
arrested a lot of them women and men HEK
dr. Phil Phil ashira como back to cali
he even a 10 years old child was
arrested Kenema while you do via you
Talib be frozen owe me an article SE
hace he was with his father demanding
the release of his mom because his mom
was a political prisoner and I'll cool
and how bad bad a hot anal had a
certaine starlet Alma don't sorry well
reified on I I believe that after these
two accidents the the countryside and
the cities in Syria went up in flames
why elicits a bobblehead village et al
amudha heart these two accidents are not
the only reasons for the demonstration
to start can you knock ethicon shabby
the wheel wobble Amanda there was a very
very long and very very harsh as popular
stress around ken who knocks yes it is
la la esta badness ladan Nizam Anna's
amla Lily alley ona sama Bashar lesson
there was a policy of slavery and and
and emulation for all the people by the
family of Bashar al-assad regime yaphet
anila I detest babs as Curitiba says
crew hottie bond and and also other
reasons I'm gonna mention it afterwards
ana winds ons tell Emma Bashar al-assad
a locum victory collar democracy a
annually de since Bashar al-assad took
over the the regime from his dad in
undemocratic way oh ha Lygia me Anna
Jose a cumbia hot Jose Akoum vita e
rosehill valid invalid
mine is almost a bit London fatter he
make an impression in everyone that he
gonna change the regime from a totally
tourism to an open and free country
wakulla no se combina Deena's lahoti
locked azhagiya L et cetera Hudson mr.
well my silliness and he said he gonna
start a lot of economic reforms that
will that will help elevate the level of
the economic system and helped elevate
their the the life of the regular person
in Syria well I can Africa what nano
khoonam fetal calf at remote ethylene
and now robama cut alhaji la hotle of
the Saudi occurred to a dealer Hamish
minute democracy and at that time we
were we were having high hopes that this
kind of economic reform may lead to a
small portion of some political reform
to resume decide attend because this is
normally what happens well again hola
quien fue surya mojados and Bashar
al-assad at abyssus Marat kabira hua hua
afraid I elit oh whoa Bob Rochelle amel
edema screen will Halloween but what
happens in Syria that Bashar Assad
brought a lot of investment external
investments and but it only put for his
own good and his family's benefits and
some few numbers of bit of Syrian
businessman mahadji lista smarter can it
that Amidala an fita shake lemme fill of
this all these investment were depends
on only a only some kind of a fake
reform and the economy that Shaquille
mubashar of coral reef be tarika Syria
daha reef victory Caesarea and it led
to a dramatic decreasing in the level of
the life of the people in the
countryside in Syria mana refill a
survey Onimusha khelat haddam EST ma Wow
Hawaii Holly semiotic ribbon Batali
shuttle [ __ ] and and and and
furthermore the the countryside before
that was having a lot of problem social
problems than economic problems and
people in it were living under the
poverty line fackin o Walda haya ala
alesis mara Alice's mera dil kabhi
reality can be ha Nizam Bashar al-assad
who arif is sorry the first victims for
the these reforms that Bashar Assad
regime started was the the countryside
of of Syria alam rasanya but Ibaka
loosed afifi Soria the other thing is
that the middle class start to vanish in
Syria that allah waka theorem banal of
Nia well for Cara and the gap between
the rich people and the poor people
start to increase dramatically yeah
novosti sarcana Sri Union mode on this
audion data kurta creamin ensured the
Holy most of the Syrians we're living
under the the the the poverty line
economically mama NOS authority laulima
Larabee and with the atmosphere of
revolutions and other Arabic countries
oma tariq al Garcia a lot e Tama feeha
comma Musa Hara Tala Tala but Billy
slovak ott and with the brutal way that
the the this the peaceful demonstration
was oppressed and while they were
demanding only reform and d regime
styler reef sri washed a little maiden
wha I'm mattel Musa heart and hysteria
cool aha the cities and the countryside
went on fire and the demonstrations were
all over Syria Yanni bestest Medina teen
Bhatia Tom Hassan attain a la fête
rocker evasion Don Huma collab dommage
who are culpable
except two major cities which were
vulnerable untouched for until recently
which is the heart of Damascus and the
heart of Aleppo well I khan muhammad ah
isla Torah but recently both series are
within the revolution they joined the
revolution the ban has a settlement a
hat and a artificial sorry Ellen okc
Renata facility Allahu fonda these
events I'm taking it really quickly and
and I'm going on with it on it very
quickly because we don't have time to to
go with on details about them yankalilla
notice any oh hai kef at the Howard has
he saw remain hutzel me Wilmot lock
allaha tensile miramos allah i wanted i
wanted to talk and on the second point
about how this a peaceful revolution
turned into from one line of peaceful
demonstrations into two branches one
military and the other s peaceful
official a larva cellula contain a
história cuneta criminal school nahar
zuma el mozo at sawatdee makan sama ha
maserati era the first four or five
months we were going into demonstrations
every friday morning and the ones in the
heart of Damascus we will call it a
lying demonstrations quick
demonstrations wah-wah Sirleaf how old
the FEMA not occur if how will damask
where I can attack anak muda heart can't
advocacy rocker on a summer fee hey Lisa
but they at the end and we were going to
other demonstrations and the countryside
but they were bigger and they were
lasted for hours I'm in Kenya tele
imaginable kami we call it fly
demonstrations the one in the heart of
Damascus because the the city was was
occupied by security forces in total
wickedness the man will care nestamay
hot iron cot cool rajul amina lava head
menina ferret early rocket MOBA sheraton
we were hard here we were hardly
gathered in one group and and we and
then the the security personnel will we
will be all over the place and and they
will jump on each one of us and that's
that will push us to fly and flee the
scene basically what can it cool Mazzara
tell me I will not lock and all these
demonstrations til now where were we are
totally peacefully aconitum on Sherrod
WL medinia democracy and the slogans we
were the carrying during these
demonstrations we're about as a
democratic and and and civil regime new
democratic and civil regime ok Nisha
'babu-bhaiya va- go soon as a tune while
as Harville rude as najas in musa hot
and the young activist men and women
used to carry olive branches and and and
flowers were during these demonstrations
what can I am kamikaze I'll Maserati
sell me a bitter eeka buta risk our CEO
Ezra me and response from the regime
they used to a press these
demonstrations in a brutal and barbaric
away Kenya come on Vidarbha limited ah
hian they beat the demonstrators I need
our bomb techs Iran happy cotton they
they beat them to the point they start
broken their bones catechu no mijo
tsunami Lester John they arrest them and
they took them to prisons way afternoon
all bad and killed some of them a
Brahmas mominul colossal at Eton too
sure Phil abney how llama Kantos ahora
by using snipers on top of buildings
around the the demonstration area wanna
saucy and she had Motel administer Bob
Amma my knee vomeronasal Abra Rochelle
Canosa kamiak no suna hamaro song I
personally watched several of these
young men and women get shot in the head
by the
sniper while they were carrying flowers
and and olive branches only kuna Nash
are boosted MA leanna leanna yani
kenosha Bobby fumi Shaquille Fallon
silly me well I hotta hotta la una hija
mía culinary mm edenia oer final
defeated Hakuna Natasha animal ba ba
dinh al bad and I had her lasha Bobby a
spot yes put a mom and a moo by sheraton
with bitter rica yani heptyl honest man
so terrazas well I kinara Rizzo anak
muda muda fazer fira so it really was a
shock for us because the person next to
you was never in you never hear a shout
the we are we're never ever actually
shouted in some of these they never
shouted any slogans they were just
standing next to you then the next
minute they are collapsing and you never
hear even the shot the bullet that hurt
him but you see the explosion on his
head habana Dan hallett isabeli chicken
at a confession con una cuadra maragua
FISA june Juanico a needle murata hadoo
nila season 18 k fire Adonis Shabaab
ms.lala nevar Valley home a lacuna home
at Lalibela t 2 bar mezcla Fionna and
other than that the torture situations
and prisons and jails was very horrible
I myself where they took me there once
and I saw the the young man hanged like
they're like carcasses in a
slaughterhouse and they hang them up
from feelings all night long tamanna
bhatia Shabaab most serene and the Kuhn
has Hill thoraseal mean nano lamb nakano
read and not all he has a terrific the
wheelman alone flee and nannies an R&R
if animism can I read juror has
essaouira ill alone pattaya cool and now
knock Fallon I saw but our hobby a comma
you read little I'm cool on your thumb
we did I'll try my best we did not want
it to go into a violent route we knew
that the regime is pushing the
revolution to turn into a violent
uprising and
and so he can say to the world that this
is a violent act of gangs and and and
vandalism and they are not actually a
Volusia NIST or activists well I can had
a summer camp Harris natok site around
imaginable in Chicago then other things
start happening and it was out of
everybody's control like soldiers start
to defect from the regime well as
officer lacombe k and i'll explain to
you how that started fue como zahara can
ya tum patrika be be my fellows at walk
men cabela system is on every
demonstration was surrounded by three
levels of regime systems or regime
people you know DJ's nizami the first
line are the actual Syrian soldiers I
shall be huh then the regime thugs or
algebra some are adjusting mahabharat
and after that are the security
individuals or the and internal
intelligence people kafka Biermann
gentleman an actor abominus wokcano
actor actor in sunny insanity met with
tamil monitors i dreamin as you still
amino Abby ha the soldiers were very
afraid of getting close to the people
and they were very merciful a lot
merciful than the the regime thugs
algebra or the security forces of the
regime well again L mahabharat do battle
mahabharat Kenya tuna awam original
visited Mutasa here in C mean and the
security forces officers the Intel in
turn internal intelligence officers used
to give the orders to the soldiers to
kill shoot directly to the to the
demonstrators what can I led a photo at
Lena's can I octal maribel regional
mahabharat and they they will shoot
every soldier who refuse to follow
orders and shoot the demonstrators
redirect our body junoon dilhara men as
a Shinigami alharbi silla Halford
eatable that's why several of these
soldiers defected from the from the
regular army and they will run away or
defect with their own personal guns or
our weapons whoa never that shackle much
muah Ben howl as you know the motion
teen mass leha to him then after that
they start to gather in groups and they
start to be to make groups and they they
basically have their own guns with them
much money he made motors i hearing
officer they started to make groups to
protect the demonstrators hua Li hey
mate I'll beauty nurse or he might build
a dwell correlati yaku mizuno delhi
university ham ham and to protect the
people's houses and in the small towns
and cities when the regime army start to
get inside wanda mojados at mercer
al-kubra fuji sushi or minocin el maadi
Hadassah and shikaka beer fish and when
the big massacre and juice Rachel or
town happens last year a big defect
defecting wave happens in the regime
army en el que si el que sirva national
Rafa do cattle ha delcam el kebir
bananas because a lot of soldiers
refused to kill and that big scale and
all these people and this in this town s
you can take a signal Mo's ahora todos
fiercer showed me some Bashar al-assad a
lot of demonstrations used to happens in
just Russia war against the regime of
Bashar lesson I can edit them is a
Malayan Maharajah because they have a
tie rod what the hams you know the Lord
the response of the regime to these
demonstrations was by bombard in the
city the town by airplanes by air forces
and then sending the soldiers the
infantry soldiers come on mr. Turkel
hadiza the Herod Bobby
more Senhor moosh whoa Elena Anna who
knock jesh Sri her bday Etta shackle
fimo asha DJ shinigami after this
accident an officer named Sailor Moon
announced that there is a free syrian
army is his on together on the
establishment establishing and we will
and this will this free army will stand
against the official syrian army the
bond badda bodda Zillmer sarah he
account till fatty harlot ibid amman
hang Nizam see asset atiba al majaz
early on Mia well moot italia this
massacre was the first started the this
policy of the regime to create massacres
and a daily basis and to kill people on
a daily basis kennedy Philby daya merged
oracle shahar in the beginning it was
like once every month they made these
massacres happening then every 10 days
or so Alex are cool young lady Amara
then it it happens every single day and
a ladina feel young I did measure there
now it's like several massacres every
day fiat madonia home because habra why
we met fire several towns were bombarded
by air forces and and land by artillery
well I Omarion habla octal minmin rail
ejection is ami an Illinois a mood Casey
Herrmann no me tienes da crib and young
million and no day will end other than
at least two hundred casualties and
excluding the casualties from the
official Syrian regime army wanna low
erect ASAP uh transition is a million oh
me oh Moo tune I done kona hawaii news
follada diem ultima manana yo me and
cola dana been almighty no crime scene
with that meet at eel fishery ax and if
you include the the regime army and the
casualties we're gonna have from 200 to
52
300 a casualty every single day in Syria
well Anna da patel vaina jai sri megami
now there is a fight between the regime
official army and the Free Syrian Army
pocket a layer muta Cafe Wha hey Adele
Bill Monroe and it's an unequal fight
and it's unjust unjust fighting en ella
Dana J nizami musella vxr estacado
Warren wat on demon because we have an
official army with with with the most
efficient and most complicated and and
developed a weapon weaponry and and
Arsenal vitara fila Dana mujeres que
cela que tomamos el aha and in the other
side you have a small brigades of armed
people let them look seriously huh
besitos it then they have only simple
weapons metallic rockets were a large
auntie Sarah welcome home BTW her ear
badal bell that and with with all these
with all that they are do having a lot
doing a lot of victories on the ground
and they are liberating a lot of small
towns well Kathy remain home York
Telamon as youth the Harrier has about
that and many of them are killed to
liberate these small towns well a
consumer that cometh to holla Tehran
mysm Bashar al-assad but the sky is
still open to the earth to the Bashar
Assad regime air force because fear Him
who will bombard the city well I guess
you know the valid missoula Lord català
him and and his soldiers are do not have
the guts to come on the ground and fight
the list here Ian army the Free Syrian
Army well dad Madame Morrible camel and
the result will be at a town totally
destructed with hundreds and hundreds of
dead people well
la fila in lezyne itaku ha and thousands
of refugees who left the these towns the
van has a Nutella teanna dem anak-anak a
sonata facility bahagia lizardy ha well
a keen as a tuaca fan dolly inter cali
modo de fe I don Herbert I fear LSD at
reddit Kashiram Phil alam again this
point need more a lot more elaborate and
detailed but i had to stop here because
I want to talk about the the the voice
of secretary on war that is on the media
nowadays the Monaco theorem car ahead
BTW physio not anime hysteria her belly
mi historia her play fear will hammer by
danica bill camel wha 'naruto severe a
sloppy i read a lot and I see a lot on
media that they describe this war as a
civil war or describe it as secretary in
war and I think this is not correct by
any mean and this is unethical yaneth
maharat and the Maharajah to be Philby
daya karo soon awhile Halloween Wilma
Seguin while Drew's were cool Atia films
to Missouri garage maharat Samia aku dan
around kanimozhi team because the
peaceful demonstrations which started in
the beginning it included all the the
ethnic groups of the Syrian community it
has the the Christians the Sydney is the
alois the Druze and and all other
components of the Syrian society mysm
Bashar Assad erf daman and now Lonnie
asada alejas isaura lmn hillel et al
harpeth even obnoxious URI Bashar Assad
regime knew for sure that it's the only
way to to to to to put down this
revolution is by creating a secretary
war between the components of the of the
Syrian people quantum mechanics were
young Jaime on yes rusian real matala
Bobby Scott Nizam Bashar al-assad canal
heady santa fe al montara ha
Oh here boo Cena shaban was here it'll
clergy I was there two more tere bin
henan agana when the peaceful
demonstrations were in the street the
first person who mentioned the term of
the sex of the secretary ISM is Bethina
shoppin who used to be who she is now
the foreign minister of Syria and used
to be the the the the immigrant Minister
the Syrian immigrant Minister cannot
economy abyss misconnect yeah but she is
actually the media spokesperson of the
of the presidential presented President
President Bashar al-assad yeah Annie
Omaha can mcculloch to Hussein Asha
Bambi mohabbat Allen had a la basura
what I did love when she mentioned that
back back there she it was like she is
announcing war on the people she's
declaring war on the on the Syrian
people and it was and it's its kind it
was kind of a threat to the Syrian
people anemic a movie Oh Ellen home come
with tax email me don't I phien a calm
Hodges Oscar eome banal here Sunni
hallelujah well how they did it the
first thing they they they separated the
towns on a secretary on basis they put
barriers and and and as military and
security barriers between the the alley
with neighborhoods and the city
neighborhoods a mobile salvado afraid la
la ooh la la vie en mode on here so now
I will well I kissed a moment I Reuben
misspell asuna they killed some alley
with people and they put their bodies in
the innocent gnus neighborhood and vice
versa and I'll for the other side to the
medulla mobbed initial shot alcoholics
to halloween at the hula ho hula a
selfie on a sewer self eun-jung padlock
on and they depends on the principle of
of spreading rumors that these
revolutionary evolutionists are Salafis
and they want on and this this this was
directed to Alois these are selfies
and they want to kill you all com BB
article almora Dean Halloween with a
whiff ahem what are we r mo tashera
Alethia my dog they arrest the every
eluate person who is against the regime
and and they arrest their families and
they threaten them and they even they
they force their families would lead to
leave their houses to y como el al majaz
urticae econo esta cosa dune anticon
Tavia Talmadge's earth IPA and they they
they they started a lot of massacres and
they did it on a secretarial basis and
they did it on purpose I can't be
further shall be humming a Halloween I
didn't where is a luna oh mia to denilla
Montek estonia welcome indeed at him
they used to bring the the regime thugs
are the shabiha they do they picked them
from the a lowest part of the of the
ugly of the Syrian community and they
send them to the Sunni areas and they
they were so to that so they can
slaughter thus any people had hurried
love this outfit Surya even the map of
of rape in Syria oh and I have come with
them a few i'm a lot of you go and this
is something I care about it and I am
documenting it does Allah FEMA nautica
tommaso toffee never happens and unless
Andy Andy Andy and the Secretary on
hotlines hexes de Guiche that Korea Iowa
Khorasani Alhassan a bottle bot where
there is a lowest villages and Sunni
villages next to each other lad Rican a
toombi more tasaka Mortaza holla home
Wow shabiha wait I do know how mr Swan
anissa they used to bring mercenaries
and the regime thugs or the shabiha and
they make them the rape women waiter
[ __ ] ass Aaron Allah no mineral oween
and dune and they do on purpose they a
nun purpose they leave
signals that refer that they are a
lowest alamba the desert a Sherman has a
long flea on me while Tom's idiot is
rami a wall while Meza well Mahathir an
associate a kid and Holland and O's
helped ahi Fe Soria heptyl on after nine
months of these a fake and fabricated
scenes by the regime and all these
massacres and all that killing I can
assure you that there is no secretarial
war in Syria Korea suniye common volusia
Malik really we owe a comic Mercer aha
there is no sin a village who attacked
an ala west village and do and massacred
them or kill them all lakyn una cuadra
de el valle verde almohada but there is
some individual response to the most
committed to the maskers wanna be right
under be hotter kardam and i see it as
as a warning for a coming danger well
cool omotola modernism massamba Charla
said cool young man amor has him Islam
and as long as this regime is staying
and authority and every single day this
regime stay there Yanni and neisseria
saticon fijo director meaning that the
danger for Syria will grow bigger and
bigger way Annie and Helena's legend
Sabharwal a cool head alcatel you allah
has heel measures early and nami i redo
the whole fee heart by fear and meaning
and that means that all these people who
were patient enough till now to to not
respond to the killing and to the
massacres because they don't want to be
in to be inside a sec returning War when
he falls over several a fluffy and they
want to protect the soul of the of the
of the of the revolution tend the soul
ethics of the revolution which include
three major points and hurry Avila
Dahlia Welker ami freedom justice and
dignity ozone and Helena's tenia come
visit our TMO site era alejado
voila voila loans led satanism there who
a break my jaw sir I think these people
can't hold up anymore and they can't
control the rage against the the
violence that the regime is starting and
the and the massacres that the regime is
doing obatala felons and a [ __ ] among
shutter and and how well has he sora e
lajara IPA is at all Homer wissam Bashar
al-assad and then the reality is we're
gonna we're gonna face the danger of
turning the revolution into a secretary
in war if this regime life still get
longer and longer yani al-hilal waheed
leer cough has hidden a hysteria oh yeah
Adam tar Road surya Eleazar activa hard
imma hua Scott amazon unless you read
shall Herbert I feel so the only
solution to stop the bloodshed in Syria
and stop the syrian from drowning in
them and the ND ND and the sea of blood
is the take down this regime who want to
lead Syria into the secretary in war
sabon knocked on here I let you out the
hadith on her who I Hadees al-qaeda was
she had you know Salafi infusoria the
last point that I want to talk about is
al Qaeda and the Salafist and jihadist
an appearance in Syria and I couldn't
see sodium in Zoabi akali legit done I
wasn't serie a few weeks ago
Aladin el que tenemos el aha she's a
[ __ ] and I was with several of the
Armed brigades of the Free Syrian Army
what's the height well I did been home
and I met a lot of them Nadine wha
cellophane even they are the radicals
and the Salafists well Hadees and al
Qaeda mo Jude Abhishek el kebir fishery
ahuja Hadees mobile a few are and I'm
saha the reality is when you talk about
al-qaeda in Syria this is an
exaggerating and it's not really
completely true I will had these on as
jihadi in a t-bar an ejection her who I
mean as she had you know cellophane
forgot I don who I had this data and
they talk about that as i see at the
Free Syrian Army his compound of
jihadist and Salafist is not the right
thing no I'm finisher laheera desolate
bad an awesome self bad lonicera selfie
away she had GI la suya yes and the last
month several of these Salafist and
jihadists who came into Syria what
kawano battle much more hot and they
created some groups well I cannot Ali
legit done but they are very few like in
a hot Sarafine observer and they are
very dangerous at the same time well
more well as are you done and they have
a well fun late day their world funded
well filling I'll ablaze swim in a
serene and most of them are not Syrians
jihadi in la robe they are from Arab
jihadists well hug but I done and that's
the biggest danger to hata get a moose
allah hafiz a shorter Fallujah home even
the the the the arm brigade and the
Syrian are free syrian army refused them
Alan ojala no no and now Judea Dean are
a blemish would read my rule by no home
they announced several times that the
the appearance of this Arab jihadists
between them is non welcome what Alabama
zayshul he'll be moderate Surya foreign
and the free army request from the the
jihadist to leave Syria immediately
lakini action Asda lonniedos but I think
that this will not happen kamasan
animism human comedy sarah has it much
more Philby diet a bomb and I believe
that the regime implanted these groups
in the beginning of the revolution
cometary fun and almanach Phil alamy
Larabee LAN hua Manassas lemme and as
you know the atmosphere in the Arab
world right now it's tend to be Islamic
well I que no es la mortadella
bellissimo serif but if the tolerant
Islam not the extreme Islam well when I
digital bae Lina's of carbonyl stepdad
and it's a natural result of half a
century of totalitarian well facial hair
catalyst are a lot of Solomon RV and the
failure of the leftists and dandy and
the Arab world one of them honest or
illogical and hotter and but I think the
idea is there they're taken over the the
authority now it's not a danger
wah-wah-wah hazardous on Marta del Valle
batik a table masala ha to shake illness
even mean home because foreign in Syria
most of the the of the fighting brigades
are from the tolerant Islamists well I
can hula has Alana Sergey Hadiya was
silly fiala him but they they include
these Salafist and jihad is coming into
Syria right now Wow empty dad fat resume
me alone la otra at wollman valley and
when the violence is prolonged longer
and longer so you a de la the fest she
and the third of Dean exr wassaic only
sally has she had gene how k kutta this
will oh this will this will make the the
religious extremists extremism to to
become more and more important and to
spread more between the fighters and
this will be a two day today to the best
of the jihadist and the Salafists didn't
my reason is on an ensemble Charlotte
lands I and this is specifically what
the regime want and I I believe that the
regime now is happy with the result
and your column on zuru has allegedly
said Sara Ann a horrible era begin he
wanted say to the world this is not a
revolution I am fighting terrorists and
he's totally a liar in this in a sorrel
and to Harry Bella I did mr. Wyatt
because the Revolutionists right now and
the revolution are fighting multi-month
on several fighting they are fighting
secretaries mhmm they are fighting the
the criminal regime of Saddam of Bashar
al-assad what to harvest LFE night on
and they are fighting the Salafist so
what horrible fo de dum misora and they
are fighting the the chaos within the
Revolution was anonymous Leah kabira and
I think they have a big responsibility
and I read the cobbler and Oscar okuma I
last see my calmly I want to add before
I thank you for listening to me I let a
kid Allah much more not to enforce some
of the points that I was talking about
another nephew bday inul musta my dually
yet rose shabby Sri ahead is Ramu Bashar
makeable putt charla said I think the
international community is leaving the
Syrian people under direct criminal
machine of the the criminal regime of
Bashar al-assad Jerry Manchester keha
dual ahlam Cola and I think this
criminal is this this crime is shared by
all the countries in the world Danya
know is a Lamia Thomas cotton exam
Bashar al-assad BS rocket mungkin second
if you don't if this regime is not going
down as soon as possible buzzin and
notorious as a call if you have toilet
lemon I think Syria will be in a war for
a long time wasn't
Bella Divya military well Hadari la cima
I think this beautiful country with all
that great heritage and history and
civilization it will I will I will go
back to the dark ages a hot idea my
secretary in war waa brucella phenom for
some sand through the Salafists
themselves like an athlon but until now
banana sir ian masala musoma mean a new
calm has a lock on a metal ocellatus
were to come on and I i think till now
the Syrian still fighting these against
these three points that I told you about
before voila RF y la mota say mutumba
besotted una and yells oh LOL harbert
idea o Allah Totoro FINMA RF yang cool
my thumb and I think I don't know when
until when they're gonna keep dying
until they turned into the air the
extremism or turned into the secretary
in war or turn the total chaos so cranky
Raonic it seamless yell at you little
head design Nala well I can also nada
aqui that you are venomous thank you
very much there's a lot of things I need
to talk about but I think this is enough
and I am opening the door for question
and answers
chuckling to see them
West Maxwell mostly phenomena she had
gene o salafi what what's the different
picture what what what access do you
want what you want to talk about that
there is Salafist and jihadist and in
the revolution will you speak in small
segments please so I can translate to
her thank you what they said what they
said
Anna Anna Anna Anna Khalil makati and I
said previously what you'd use what you
said right now and an occult and no no
not cry the file and also has a merger
they are saying there is a hida in Syria
but this is not true yomo Judean fee
holub no judy holliday are Hollow and
halak el khalili night on but they are
very few my lanta Ted the scene on
muscular and I don't know any mean huh
you're talking about a problem that we
are having actually at casinos atif is
sariah comin with us we're ledesma by
sheraton when a'kla holla holla a lot of
activists in the evolution are our
photograph are filming the Act the
activities and the actions what happens
in the revolution and move and broadcast
it to the world wait for man hyah TM
seminal is Alec and they pay from their
blood and their lives as a result for
that Danish obnoxious messy hey
Maharaja's mobile cell shraddha catalou
ya know young young cat my a dose we
have a activist vassal chadha he's a
christian and he was killed because he
was it was broadcasting what happens
well Dana Aiden Morris I don't pata
luffy holla be annoying police got a
small Tamara one and another director
his name is Tamara wommen aleppo he was
killed because he was broadcasting the
truth wow I do dizzy and he is from from
Al Drew's he's not Sunni yeah yeah Nina
no no Ana Manhattan mushkila an attack
on an emotional and agile has been agile
knucklehead madhulika and we are
suffering from this and I think my job
here is to tell you some of that the
truth of what happening on our own
ground there's a lot more than than me
Jana Jana Pumbaa Delilah Surya oughtta
be Terry well sir I go into Syria by
smuggling routes and and secrecy yeah
christopher lon so i can and so i can
tell you the truth has had my dad know
my magic illness sabe sobre this is one
of the biggest problems and one of the
hard problem that we have in their Lucia
yanny Yanni and tell 00 lat 0 fossil
mojados FIFA Tala here officially a
low-budget an astoria Doreen as who are
a lotta her little are the unforeseen if
you go back and study the details about
what happens on the last time and the
last few months in Syria so you will
realize that the Revolutionists are able
to to liberate themselves a bruh ese
heceta with their simple weapons babra
shotty ammo multi-home and through their
courage and their death well a consumer
math to her diamond Joseph Bharat
Bhushan men cabela news on but the sky
are always open for the bashar or
regimes air force and as on another
house of a desert I around Zoe I think
we only need a no-fly zone
himali
they don't know anything
no cave continue please Anna Anna Kate a
gambas al ano balita by hadees hacker
yeah new well continue and and add of
what he said yeah and i had academies
aloneness atara do neha's images 0 ha ha
come to facil and a lot of people are
are and on these massacres and he gave
you a little more details not had the
San massager I assure artois me at well
Tim silver Jesus were the festiva thira
we're talking about massacres for
hundreds and Tenzin and hundreds of
people and they will manipulate the
bodies and and other details I don't
want to mention now and i will return as
al annual a terminally the admin come
hazama sphere are you a head menina
ahead minkum Winifred and hayden ma
ottawa scatter Allahu Allah to I I want
to ask and I I wish you never be input
in this position if anyone come and kill
your family jf sa ashore Fallon what are
you gonna feel about it ladainian is ami
akhon biscotti me at Allah for Allah we
have a regime that kills and killing
thousands hundreds and thousands of
families lot fallecio and missile cool
cool yeah true home by shoomlah Anakin
home Lache kanamu Jared jihad he killed
them and groups I kill kids and and and
women and elder people he killed them
like they're nothing like they are like
some kind of furniture or something and
non-living people who are cool No lometa
Anna
arif welaka me last year and I'm 9s and
ya KU need a hammer share in sunny FL
Rodham he asked to when but and i don't
know and i can't i can't prevent people
from feeling anger and rage about for
happening a lot of wasilla hander my ash
to me on when you when you combine anger
and outrage with with with with with
weapons lenta considerable hair has a
muckle toe shoe la la mata Syria will
not be a fine again and this is what i
said but i don't know when it's gonna
end meenal mungkin and and and the cool
who knock her puffy a monk and a
startled badam and Lennar meta sayin
fisher has a lot of meta sighs montana's
and has his it could be there will there
might be gonna be happened as a
secretary in war we we never know when
these people until when these people
gonna stop again I'm gonna keep patient
and not respond or react to this unjust
and jam taken ill obama-clinton an
advocate no longer more to mean well
Ellie dune exactly shabbos sorry you're
talking about obama and clinton and i
don't i think they don't care and i
think they don't want to help the Syrian
people Bachmann sous vide SRO colony
read Masada sha tsui Noreen mucha Masada
to sha tsui from the beginning of the
revolution there they keep repeating
that we need to help the people the
Syrian people we need to help the Syrian
people well lack in may have the soil
acts but what happens is the opposite
julion desde el Mashad airways dad el
cotillo every day the the maskers
increased and the killing increase wom
sami teen a la langue cool Osama tone
active Otto an occult on onlv desirae me
la la tiene la alum as midi mafia
America be mafia forenza una feeha
Britannia I was seen the hamel door he
away Russia away Iran i dun Alyn culo
motivated she hated them and but they
are keep silence the whole world is
sharing this this silence crime
everybody is sharing his his burden of
this blood and they are all
they are all participate in this crime
the United States the UK France Iran and
China when a felony tamanna Minamata ha
des la comida to love didn't at a man
not too shabby allaha KU mati calm and
when I talk to you guys to the students
specifically I hope that you can start
some kind of pressure movement towards
your government Jenny had a cool melody
know this is all what we can offer
you
yes
thank you very much yeah yes please and
sign it
Yanni and a ménage à is yani the Salamis
mas boots off a car battery car Lana
Felicia if we think that way that it's
gonna be a symbolic we are not gonna do
anything well I canoga has a man be cool
at the Fosse but we need to take care of
all details when a shabbos suria stock
ICJ zoellazoella car Jimmy on trulia has
a mocha leave this jameon a gelato shop
judy has his jay-z I believe the Syrian
deserve this Nobel Prize so please go to
the website and sign the petition and I
want me to be metaphor small detail I
know it's not really gonna happen but
fun
I can understand because they are
yes jaani jaani lucky no Danny had the
moon charon aqui aqui bit of solano la
casa Bob Maholm yeah Adam asad ullah
shah suri yes well I can well I get an
African her neck dophia delmar de ce s
ye larka I believe that there is a
weakness and E and the political
revolution a political side of the
revolution layer khalila hua tuo
Mohammed Asha bisutti and and this
weakness has had you can't compare it
with it with with with with with with
his strong and willing and and and there
the the the the good work of the people
of Syria well I can who knock la da da
da da da Hallion yani shekel Minaj
kalmar de cumbia al-fatah CSEA a lard
butt and there is some small of
political work that the the the parties
the political parties are doing on the
ground in Syria welcome with Canada
competency Maharaja charitra star by a
not so elegant and circle mahalia will
he'll Amelie sobre wojek el jadida WR
che and fashion with the war and they
are arranging the demons they used to
arrange the day the police the peaceful
demonstrations and they do the
arrangement between the groups and
between other cities and lee jonathan
circle mahalia the the local the local
arrangement committees and then the
general committee of the revolution
Anna's ona na hoona mirada GD is shakal
on set a [ __ ] bed deal activity and Alma
are the tackle ed I think these people
will be a good political they have a
good political stance and they will be a
good replacement for the traditional
political parties that used to be
against the regime
yes so do you yes thank you
you
no that's okay i can understand yeah
okay a number on about it No nom I think
yes yes jaani jaani Lana Lana satyana
burak essiac a Cyrano gesture her Ethel
and Romanichal mojesh kb rally here much
Yanni who know what geez wataniya qadam
I think I think even the word army is a
very big 40 to describe this the Free
Syrian Army they are the the small seed
of a new coming army wanna ledee kanaha
kuvira and he has auto by cheryl i said
fat LKC manasunu dododo bot D'Aquila
jesh say it's roni logiciel for on
caffeine and i believe if the regime
collapse or other Bashar Assad fall all
the features and the soldiers in the end
it official army will come back to the
to this to the Free Syrian Army Somali
big they were freaky benediction is
omni-wazul Harlan there's main
difference between the the the regime
army and the free army Anastasia told
her you'd a fair and hurry unhurried but
I'd be cami Li you define our tea daily
daleko isn't them the Free Syrian Army
have a they believe and and they are
defeat they are defending for the whole
country and they have a belief that to
defend and that's why they are very
strong well I can edition is on me the
day he a man enough ya know you that
found chanceries one amazon wiley about
while the the regime army has a very
very weaker belief because they are
defeated they are defense they are
defending the the president and and its
and his family and the regime only
videla card Isaiah Cyril hurry accumbens
imitation is ami diamond this is why on
the ground the Free Syrian Army always
beat the the regime army a tie rod
faculty I'm
there's a luau tomorrow only the regime
Air Force what what what helps the
regime army to take over and come back
again
okay okay I understand okay Anna's on a
nominal yani mean I love acai and Nicole
and home and the massage school Bashar
Assad and a serious at Combe bahama
Bashar Assad it's not realistic really
to say that when Bashar Assad fall Syria
will be in a good shape right away marca
de no se que una cuadra mean alfo da
I'll her up it's I can assure you that
there will be a period of of chaos and
destruction y el Fatah Toby reality
tomorrow feeha al muslimin how lacked a
real Cobra and this is normal when a
society going through a very major
historical change well they keep cool
have a akuto eternally stepdad and and
you should remember we still have these
all these all ancient all these ages of
oppression sorry Alan chocolate
Democrats eleniak own salon so the way
to democracy will not be easy another
other sharat saxena what I think there
will be tens of years well I keno Aquila
kyun ho ngoc Frank Omaha Surya Cassie
raphe I did build on Phil Harris with
the devil tamil actor heey William elizy
SE le Scott lesson but I can assure you
that there is groups and and and and a
lot of Syrian people inside and out are
preparing for the for the day when the
regime is falling well my Long Beach no
home in a Shabaab and they are young
activists and they're working hard last
question please okay
okay last questions
but then never mmm LOL [ __ ] and boosters
fayette kenya tumko spa hetalia
mesajiniz illa first of all you should
know that the hospitals are the first
part we're bombarded so people won't get
help if they get injured a lot of ba la
zenia Columbia saphenous CM cut l'homme
au watch akala home the doctors who
helped people injured people will be
arrested or get killed el Mashad film
idania alakija come Asha Bobby so nihaal
en casa al jaha yet Uncas possible
Madhava the temporary field hospitals
that they were made by activists and in
the field to help the injured people
were bombarded ledecky laughing Medina
Talib Mach 2 on health care about Wilma
wanna know Mom Karissa and sunny Aleppo
don't have water or power now right now
and we are we are facing a humanitarian
disaster elbonian tatty ll madanm you
tomorrow the infrastructure of my most
of the cities is destructed jolly beetle
ahia Phil mudanza arimo hasara most of
the neighborhoods in the end
evolutionary cities or towns are under
siege 1 sv a felony tar road only jaha
creepy and people are starving for real
ladina i love allah azza milani milani
no added kabir million la la la la
Fredrik ambedkar me a legend feed our
history I can't tell you the exact
number but i think there will be that we
have about two and a half million
refugees inside Syria itself a lot fall
when missa where juliano muneshwara will
had a clammy a lot of kids and women and
men are sleeping in the parks are and in
the public streets was she that car them
and we have all inter coming that's for
you this is the health situation in
Syria right now
yes
you
yeah neeya naana Hoffa's or halloween
yani yahoo a murmur catcall Elin
Jamieson and nallakunta a few but
understood no I think the fear and the
panic and the a lowest is a little
complicated because the Sunnis already
have their secretary and stress well a
canal doin illallah we feel assess
common his arm and moons would be
diabetes litmus on me ham from the
beginning the regime gave weapons to
most of the a lowest won't fill assess
how fino Missourian and band they are
from the beginning are afraid and and
panicked 130 and a long voyages amino
hope deathly and as you as you know the
violence is it part of it is in your
eternal fear rosella kala ardell Walker
al Casey romania cumin will tell ya tebe
Hammond is ominous shabiha Janna FEMA
not my animal a cell cool anak should be
home in a raka the hell abou knock
shabiha sauna but most of the places
where the regime has it is using thugs
and and I would like we call them
shabiha are but not all the places
because when you from there is thugs
from a red paw there's tags Sydney's in
Aleppo there are Sunnis thugs in an
alley pose well I can film unix surah
how creepy a Yanni later doc theater
maman well I can surah I'm a physician
and pneumonia com well cut it fusion
engine although shall be home in a
Halloween but in general there is no the
picture which is not completely correct
that who do the killing are the soldiers
and the the regime thugs from a Lewis
hammered air hockey table not lock and
as I told you this is not real engine
and totally lacking Anna
Halloween stealing the whole feature
petal mode when I shall know how I feel
Fallon I i believe the a lowest will
fight to death because they are afraid
for real with Alec and I shall see an
ottoman and you attempt to head home I
wish they will be they can be a set
aside in the Indy conflict wanna
nominate simcha tub at Erick Sermon
futaba homeland need Shiva heey ascetic
ribbon beep and I think I'm i'm close to
desperate and i don't i don't believe
they will listen so i would i would
prefer to talk to the other side because
the other side will listen a little bit
anna bahagia Ellen shikaka Biermann
badri shallot has hit toffee we need a
big defect from some of the of the major
men in this secretary in group at the
letter shore I met Halloween and now
says ever Bashar Assad felony raccoon
who knocked man like me huh so most of
the a lowest don't believe or don't feel
that if Bashar al-assad is gone they
will be without a protection I think
it's enough and it's difficult question
yes please last question
thank you
yani Anna Kosovo knock p.m. silica
Syrian LOL Torre Del Rio de hielo to
career and avocado not the Satya well I
can asuna Nala to read I I think if the
united state decided they can do it and
there's a lot of examples of that but i
think they don't want to thank you very
much